Narrator:
The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
If the sharks hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
you're a hero.
It's very innovative.
Lori's squawking --
What are we doing here?
Narrator:
...and They'll fight each other
for a piece of the action...
What is going on
with Cuban this season?
You guys have no vision
whatsoever.
...but first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I'm seeking
a $2 million investment.
Wow.
How twisted is that?
Narrator:
It's sink...
bobber up.
And bam.
Please don't mess this pitch up.
Narrator: ...or swim.
I'll make the first offer.
No. I want to make
the first offer.
Excuse me.
No, I want to make
the first offer.
I want to make
Whoa!
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner, the queen of qvc,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban -- Notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
are Jeff Stafford
and Dusty Holloway
with a product they believe
is going to explode
in the fishing market.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jeff Stafford,
and this my longtime
hunting and fishing buddy
Dusty Holloway.
Our product
is the shell bobber.
We are seeking $80,000
in exchange for 20% equity --
That's 20% of the coolest
fishing accessory
to ever hit the market.
Now, earlier this year,
Dusty and I went hunting,
and after firing
a shotgun,
the empty shell fell into the
water and floated perfectly.
I immediately thought,
"That'd be a really cool
fishing bobber."
The market would be huge,
as we'd be combining
two complementary
multibillion-dollar industries,
hunting and fishing.
So we took the bobber
and we went to work.
The first thing we did
was deprime it.
And after depriming it,
we stuffed it
with a floatable material.
And after that,
we inserted a cap
to make it look
real pretty-Like.
And then, once you do that,
you insert a wooden dowel
with slot in it
for the fishing line
and then a spring on top of that
to make it stay on the line.
Bobber up.
And bam.
We had our very first
shell bobber.
We were in love.
In order to find out
if others would be as excited
about the product as we were,
we had to test the market.
I took the prototype
and I called on local
bait-And-Tackle shops.
People loved it so much,
they were actually stealing it
off the shelves.
We tested the market,
we proved the concept,
and now we're here
looking for help,
because we know every store
that sells fishing accessories
is going to want to sell
the shell bobber.
With a product this hot,
our passion, and your expertise,
I know we can get it
in every one of those stores.
So, sharks, which one of you
can I get on my hook,
and which one needs
a three-Second head start?
[ gun cocks ]
[ laughter ]
Jeff, I wonder if we have to use
all dead shells.
Why not keep them alive
so when the fish pulls on it,
it blows it
right out of the water?
Cuban: That's what I thought
you were doing anyway.
Yeah, but that wouldn't
have been a fair fight.
Harrington:
So, Jeff, they're real shells?
Stafford: They are real
shotgun shells -- 100%.
And what's your cost?
Our cost for the three-Pack
like that
is actually under $1.
Under $1.
And what are you selling it for?
We retail that for $8.99.
Wow.
So, Jeff, this is
an important question,
because I love fishing.
I love the whole thing,
but $80,000 for 20% --
Please don't
mess this pitch up --
What are the sales?
So in our market test,
we sold 440 units.
It was a little
under $1,000.
[ laughter ]
Jeff, now I understand
why you brought the shotgun.
[ laughter ]
'cause that's the only way
you're getting money today.
So I want to just make sure I'm
getting everything straight.
You've sold less than
$1,000 worth of product?
Correct.
Daymond, he said they were
flying off the shelves,
what do you mean they were
flying off the shelves?
You know, honestly,
this is brand new to us,
but to give you
an example --
Ace hardware put us
in a pilot location,
and they were selling
about a bobber a day.
For us, it doesn't sound like
flying off the shelves,
but for them in the
fishing-Accessory world --
they're a hardware store.
They had people coming in
buying a screwdriver.
They ended up
buying a bobber.
They're not
looking for this.
Right.
They put us in another location
for about the same success.
Well, there's 4,400
ace hardwares.
If we can get in that, that's
1.6 million bobbers a year.
Are you selling these online?
Do you have a patent, trademark?
Is everything locked up
with all this?
We've got a provisional patent
on the shell itself.
We've trademarked
"Shell bobbers"
and We've trademarked
the name "Fishing ammo."
do you see anything wrong
with the valuation
that you've put on the company?
Honestly,
for a start-up company
that hasn't really
officially launched a product,
it's very tough
to come up with any valuation.
Yes. I agree.
What we did was we decided
how much money we needed
to get this going
the proper way,
with the machines,
the inventory, legal fees,
turning that
into a real patent,
and then
some operational expenses.
I think it's gonna sell.
I really do.
I think people
are gonna buy this thing
if you get distribution,
which could be challenging.
There's probably a distributor
in your sector
that supplies 80%
of the fishing-tackle stores.
You don't know
who that is yet, right?
Yes, I do.
Okay. Have you
shown it to them?
No.
Why not?
I'm kind of a perfectionist
in that I didn't really want to
take it to a lot of places
until I was confident
we had a product and packaging
that would be impressive.
I think
there's something here.
I'm willing to make you
an offer.
I haven't finished.
I'll make the first offer.
No, I want to make
the first offer.
Excuse me.
No, I want to make
the first offer.
I want to make
Whoa!
I'm getting
the shotgun.
People normally
would give you three --
I think there's
market confusion.
Well, people would normally
give you three times,
five times sales
if you're lucky.
I'm willing to offer you
eight times sales for 20%,
and you raise
the other the $72,000...
Cuban:
That's not an offer!
...from one of the other sharks.
That's like picking up
a Crumb and saying,
"I just handed you
a cake."
I gave them
eight times sales!
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary:
He's just messing around.
He's not being a shark.
He's being a minnow.
Exactly.
I'll make you a real offer.
You ready?
Please. Please.
Here's how
it's gonna work.
I'll give you $80,000
for 50%, all right?
But how do I get
my money back?
So here's
what we're gonna do.
Every time you sell one,
I get 50 cents, all right?
And after I get my money back,
that drops down to 10 cents.
That simple.
You know what? That's not
a bite. That's a throw-back.
Greiner:
Wait, Jeff, Dusty --
It was better than Daymond's,
I have to say.
[ laughter ]
That's True.
John: Whoa.
What am I here?
At least we're improving.
You got two non-offers.
Put aside the nonsense.
How are you gonna scale?
'cause the challenge --
It's not a lot of money.
You know, you guys
don't need a lot of cash
'cause your margins
are huge, right?
So that's not the issue.
I'm guessing you were afraid
to go to the distributors
because if they gave you
a big order,
there's nothing
you can do.
If we sold 10 million of these
a year, what are you gonna do?
I could make 10 million
in a year.
You're gonna do them?
You're gonna
make 10 million a year?
Myself? No.
Just simple question --
just how?
There's reloading machines,
crimps them,
and then the last thing
we have to do
is put the dowel
on them.
So it's still
a manual process
where you've got to
have someone
physically doing
the Insertion?
Yeah.
A part of the money
that we're looking for
is to get out of his garage
and into a place
where we can
keep the inventory,
a few new machines
that we need to purchase,
and then a few people
making an hourly wage
that we can just have
stuffing the bobbers.
Now, listen.
We're talking, we're squawking.
But nobody's making any offers.
I'm the only one.
Before you consider
Kevin's offer, let me...
you gonna
throw something at them?
Well, let me throw something
at you.
I don't think you really have
a company yet.
I think you have
a cool product.
Will it sell
in the millions
that you can build
an entire company around?
I don't know.
I'm out.
I love fishing.
I'm not being funny.
I probably fish about five
or six times a month.
It's a great idea.
I think it's too soon for me
because it's such a small,
you know, proof of concept,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Greiner:
I have a question.
Yes.
The provisional patent,
obviously a utility patent,
what did your attorneys
tell you?
What were their thoughts
as to whether or not
they think you'll get a patent
on this?
Well, we actually did
the provisional ourselves.
So you did not do
an extensive search.
No, I have not
done an extensive search.
But, you know, I would be
willing to do a deal
contingent upon
a search being done
and having you feel
more comfortable about it.
Wow.
He's got confidence.
Were you thinking
of doing --
Like, you started to talk
about other extensions.
We've had a couple people
ask us for --
there's glow-in-the-dark
for nighttime fishing
where We actually can get clear
shells and do glow-in-the-dark.
You can do glow-in-the-dark
plastic, yeah.
And we're going to do
a saltwater shell, as well,
that rattles
to attract the fish.
So yeah, we can do
different variations.
O'Leary: The question is --
You have no offers.
Lori's squawking,
not doing anything.
I'm not squawking.
I'm the only offer you have.
What are we doing here?
Well, any other offers?
Lori? Mark?
Doesn't look good.
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Jeff and Dusty have an offer
from Kevin O'Leary,
but they're hoping to get a
better offer from Lori or mark.
Question is --
You have no offers.
Lori's squawking,
not doing anything.
I'm not squawking.
I'm the only offer you have.
What are we doing here?
Well, any other offers?
Lori? Mark?
Doesn't look good.
What was your offer
again?
It was so horrible
I don't remember it.
I will have to have him
recap that, actually.
You ready?
It's very simple.
You know, I never forget
a good offer,
so I'm able to tell it to you
again with ease.
I give you the $80,000
for 50%.
Every time you sell one,
I get 50 cents
until I get my $80,000 back,
and then it drops to a dime.
It's that simple.
Yeah, you know, honestly,
I don't think we're comfortable
giving away 50% just yet.
You know what, guys?
You just gave the right answer.
You're getting out there
and hustling
and doing it
the exact right way.
So for that reason,
I'll make you an offer.
I'll offer you the $80,000,
and I want 33%.
Not 33 1/3%
so we're all the same,
but 33%, so this way, you both
own more stock than I do, right?
So it's still
your baby,
and you guys have
all the incentive --
but $80,000 for 33%.
What's wrong with you?
Greiner: [ laughs ]
I see nothing wrong
with you.
Deal?
He must be scared
of that shotgun.
What are you
talking about?!
yes or no, guys. You got to be
able to say yes or No.
These guys put a shell
on a --
You got to be able
to say yes or no.
Yes, we will accept
your offer, Mark.
Done.
Greiner: Oh, my God.
I wasn't even out yet.
John: Shocking.
Mark, you're the one.
[ laughs ]
of course.
Congratulations, guys.
Good job.
What is going on
with Cuban this season?
What do you mean?
I take great deals
And make them better.
You guys just have no vision --
None whatsoever.
Oh, my god.
They put a shotgun shell
on a string.
Are you kidding me?
You guys have no vision
whatsoever.
That's a horrible,
horrible deal.
You guys just don't know
how to invest in people, then.
You really don't.
These guys are doing
everything exactly right.
Why did you put
such a high valuation on it?
You spent more than that
last night on cocktails.
So?
Thanks to mark Cuban
and his investment
and belief
in our product,
shell bobbers
are gonna be a reality
in every fishing store.
We are gonna be living
the American dream.
Narrator: In season 3,
Billy Blanks jr. Made a deal
with Mark Cuban and Daymond John
for his workout system,
dance with me.
I would definitely take
that deal.
John:
Don't make me cry.
Let's see what he's up to now.
John: I brought Billy Blanks jr.
To boise, idaho, today
for a special meeting
I've arranged
with the largest online
fitness company in the world.
What's up?
Hey. Daymond John.
Bodybuilding.Com is huge.
They have 20 million viewers
a month.
This is perfect
for Billy Blanks jr.,
and it's a huge deal.
Billy is about
changing lives,
and I knew that
bodybuilding.Com
is about changing lives
as well.
We heard your story.
I was talking with Dean.
I was like, "We have to
do content with this guy."
We want to put you in front
of our 20 million users
and get your content
on our website.
We want to get started
on this deal today.
We've got a contract
ready to go.
We have the gym
and our video team on standby,
and we're shooting content
this afternoon.
Wow.
This is awesome.
Blanks: I knew Daymond
and mark would deliver.
I had no idea that
I was gonna be filming today.
[ chuckles ]
but I'm excited about that.
One, two, three.
We are truly excited
about this deal
with bodybuilding.Com.
This is our first big deal.
It's gonna help us reach
a whole new Audience
and help us bridge that gap
between Dance and fitness.
Oh, yeah!
Come on. One.
And we're really excited
because over the next 12 months,
we're projecting to hit
our first million dollars.
"Shark Tank"
has truly changed our lives.
Tracey:
My name's Tracey Noonan,
and this is my daughter
Danielle.
We're from Cohasset,
Massachusetts.
Danielle: And our company
is Wicked Good Cupcakes.
We're from Boston, and
everything's wicked pissa here.
[ both laugh ]
our cupcakes are baked fresh
daily from scratch.
No boxes or mixes
are ever used.
I am head baker,
and she is head decorator.
You need any help
with Anything?
Tracey: Danielle and I
have always been very close.
We make all our decisions
together.
[ scoffs ]
No. No, we don't.
She makes most of
the decisions all the time.
Mom, the red velvets
are done.
We're at a point where
our company is growing too fast
for us to keep up,
and we actually have a new twist
on how to share our wicked good
cupcakes with the nation.
Oh, this was
only half a dozen?
Yeah.
Are you worried the sharks
won't understand our accent?
No, I'm not worried
they won't understand us.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Tracey Noonan,
and this is my daughter
Danielle.
We own and operate
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
We're here today
seeking $75,000
in return for a 20% equity
in our company.
Two years ago,
buttercup moved out.
As a mom,
I was heartbroken.
I decided we should take
cake-decorating classes
as a way to spend some time
together.
Well, before we knew it,
in October 2011,
Wicked Good Cupcakes
was born.
We received tons of requests
to ship our cupcakes nationwide.
It was a big challenge, though,
trying to figure out
how to keep them fresh
and intact,
and that's when we came up
with the idea
of shipping them
in a jar.
Our cupcake jars
are baked fresh daily.
We layer them with homemade
frosting and filling,
ship them in gift boxes
with spoons
so they're ready to eat
right out of the package.
Basically, they appeal
to anyone with a mouth.
[ laughter ]
We're not afraid
to work hard.
Our days right now average 13
to 14 hours, plus.
Mom's definitely getting
her fair share of time with me.
So, which of you sharks
will be the first
to sink your choppers
into our sweet deal?
It's definitely a risk
worth taking.
We found that there's a lot
of dough to be made from batter.
[ laughter ]
BOTH: Thank you.
We got to try it.
We actually have some
for you to try.
They're wicked good.
Danielle: They also have
a much better shelf life
thanks to the jars.
[ laughs ]
Harrington:
Can I have a "Jah"?
is that -- "Jah"?
jar.
I love your accent.
O'Leary:
Where are you from?
Boston.
The middle one's
for you.
Thank you.
No problem.
Cookies and cream
is for you.
Oh, my God.
This is so good.
Thank you, buttercup.
[ laughs ]
Well, ladies, let me say,
welcome to the shark tank...
thank you.
...from a fellow Bostonian.
I live on Marlborough Street.
Oh, I love
Marlborough Street!
That is one damn good jar
of cake.
It's the bomb, literally.
Unbelievable. Look at this.
It's gone already.
Here's another jar
for you, Mark.
[ laughter ]
You're killing me.
How many have you sold
so far, Tracey?
From January
of this year,
we've sold $73,000
worth of jars.
Our cupcake shop
has sold $150,000,
including the $73,000
of the jars.
So you have a store.
We have a retail storefront,
as well, since october 2011.
Are we being asked to invest
in the retail store
and the jar cupcake company?
We're actually offering
a piece of both...
let me try yours.
...the retail shop
as well as the jars.
No.
Basically,
our sales right now
for this year
are slated to be $360,000.
The growth potential that
we have discovered with these
is phenomenal.
Tracey, it's not patented.
Someone else
can put a cake in a jar
and ship it
across the country.
Absolutely,
they could.
So tell me
what your plan is.
How are you going to grow
this business quickly
so that if I give you $75,000,
I get richer?
That's all I care about.
We want to be the Ben & Jerry's
of cupcakes in a jar.
How many days
is the shelf life of a jar?
Seven to 10.
So you've got bake it
and sell it right away
and ship it,
'cause it's gonna be
two days
before It's
in somebody's mouth, right?
Correct.
Have you talked to anybody
about extending the shelf life?
'cause I know
it's something you can do.
Yeah -- with preservatives.
You know, we --
if you put preservatives in,
does it taste this wonderful?
That's the exactly
the question --
Will it alter the taste?
What does each one cost to make,
and what do you sell them for?
The 8-Ounce jars
cost $2.15 to make.
We retail that
for $5.95.
The 16-Ounce jar
costs $3 to make,
and we retail that
for $8.95.
O'Leary: This product
will never be in retail.
It's always going to be
an online.
Somebody buys it, you bake it,
you send it overnight to them.
Actually, we do have
some wholesale clients.
We have a Coffee Company
up in Massachusetts.
What are you charging her
a jar?
We're charging her
$3 a jar.
It's not enough margin
for you.
Okay,
but here's the thing --
We're buying in such
pathetic bulk right now.
Okay, Tracey,
your best-case scenario --
I give you
the $75,000.
Yep.
Tell me
what your margins will be.
Sure.
Right now it costs you $2.15
to make the small one
and $3 for the big one.
Right.
How much can you reduce
the cost?
I believe we can get
the smaller jars down to $1.45.
The question I have is --
On the Mason jars,
are there any alternatives
that would allow you
to reduce your costs
considerably?
I got to say the Mason jars are
a really big draw for people.
O'Leary: Exactly.
Greiner: You can see it.
It's motherhood
and apple pie.
Exactly.
It's a homemade product
in a crafty container.
Right.
It suggests homemade, right?
Exactly, and people
do say that to us.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with your packaging.
I just think you might need
a better supplier
for the jar itself.
Maybe you're not buying
at a big enough bulk.
We need more money to buy
in bigger bulk -- Bottom line.
That's why we're here.
Tracey, as you can tell,
I'm not a big dessert guy, so...
you can pass yours
down this way.
I know. This is really good.
It's carrot cake.
Pass that to Mark.
There's definitely
a novelty aspect to it,
because I've never heard of
a cupcake in a jar.
So I think you can sell
some of those.
How did you
like the product?
It's too sweet for me.
But I have concerns with
the retail and jar aspect of it,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Well, thank you.
Danielle: Thank you.
Robert's not
a big dessert eater.
I am, and if I invest
in this company,
I'll be a bigger and bigger
and bigger desert eater.
[ laughter ]
and I'm afraid,
because I love the product.
Well, we work there,
and we look pretty good.
We'll limit you.
I won't look the same.
Trust me.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
You know,
I have now tried three.
They are fantastic.
They are wicked good.
The problem is it's just not
going to have a long shelf life,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Cupcakes are super-Scorching
hot right now,
and there's just so many people
going into this space.
That's not really
where my specialty is,
and I think you guys
are gonna do great things.
But it's really not a fit
for me, so I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Come on, Mr. Wonderful.
[ laughs ]
I'm gonna make you an offer.
You may not like it.
I love the product.
I hate the margins.
I'll give you the $75,000.
I don't want any equity.
I want $1
from every jar.
Oh.
A dollar?
Silence, please.
Let me get the offer out.
I want $1 from every jar
until I get my $75,000 back,
which means you have to sell
75,000 jars, all right?
And then I want it to drop
to 50 cents in perpetuity.
Whew.
And you decide
what to do with the business.
Can we just scoot out
in the hall for one second?
Trust me. You're not gonna get a
worse offer than that.
So you probably
should talk.
Thank you.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Harrington: How much money
does that leave them with
if they give you a dollar?
Practically nothing.
[ laughter ]
Think of
what you're doing, Kevin.
Hey, listen.
This will give them incentive
to figure
their margin problem out.
[ laughs ]
I like my deal,
and I'll sleep tonight
with a cupcake beside me.
[ laughter ]
All right.
So, Tracey, Danielle,
welcome back.
Thank you.
Four sharks were out, and
Mr. Wonderful made you an offer.
He's giving you the $75,000,
but he wants no equity.
He wants $1
off every cupcake jar
until he gets paid back,
and then 50 cents
from there on in
until you can't bake
any more.
[ chuckles ]
Don't do a deal that could
cripple your business.
Greiner:
I agree with him.
Don't do something
that you'll regret afterwards.
Oh, Tracey,
talk is so cheap.
Okay, we'd like
to come back to you
with 40 cents a jar
in perpetuity.
Damn.
45 cents, you have a deal.
Come to mama.
[ laughter ]
[ groans ]
Oh, my goodness.
That's great.
Thank you.
Harrington: Wow.
O'Leary:
That's wonderful,
and the product
really is fantastic.
Get baking.
Good luck.
Congratulations.
It was nice
meeting you.
Bye.
I'm gonna be very happy.
Mr. Wonderful
will see his return
sooner than he thinks,
and we're just gonna do great.
Narrator:
Next up is Aaron Lemieux,
who's hoping to generate
lots of interest
in his revolutionary
new product.
Hello.
My name is Aaron Lemieux.
My company is tremont electric,
and I'm seeking
a $2 million investment
for a 22% equity stake
in my company.
Whoa.
Mm-hmm.
Mobile electronic devices,
smartphones --
It seems like our entire lives
are revolving around these days.
But they have one fatal flaw --
The batteries always run out
whenever we need them the most.
But you don't need to worry
about that anymore.
We have a technology
that allows us
to harvest an energy
that's all around us.
Introducing our first product --
The award-Winning npower Peg,
the world's first
human-Powered charger
for mobile electronic devices.
This takes
your human walking Motion
and turns it into the power
that you need.
Simply place it inside of a bag
and go about
your daily activities.
The Peg stores your power
for when you need it the most --
when you're out of power and
you're away from a wall outlet.
With this investment
and the right partners,
we'll be able to change
the way the WORLD makes energy.
Can I see it, Aaron?
Yes, sir.
And all you have to do --
It's by motion. It has to move.
You can't have it
sitting somewhere still.
That is correct.
How long does it hold
its power or energy?
Hold its charge?
Yeah.
That's actually
one of the interesting features
of this product.
Because it has a kinetic-Energy
generator built into it,
it's continuously recharging
the battery that's inside of it.
I see you have
a lot of patents up there.
Yes, ma'am.
Can you tell us
What those cover?
They cover the BASIC
operating principles of this.
So no one else can do it?
That is correct.
Aaron, I keep it
in my backpack or briefcase --
Mm-hmm.
How much power do I have there
after eight hours?
Depending on how rapidly
you walk,
you could have
up to a 20% recharge
in your cellphone.
So, who is this for?
Is this for
the everyday person,
or do you want this for hikers,
people in the wilderness,
boaters, people
who are in positions
where they really
may need energy?
That is our initial
target market --
people that have
a very compelling need
to be able to have mobile power
When they need it,
where they need it.
What's the science
behind it?
The science
is kinetic-Energy harvesting.
The generator component --
We use the faraday effect,
which is a magnet passing
through an induction Coil.
How much do you sell them for,
and how many have you sold?
We sell them for $199.
We've been selling them
through our web store,
and we've sold 1,300 of them
up until this point.
What does it cost you
to make them?
It costs us
about $110 to make them.
It's expensive.
It is.
It was very much
a proof of concept,
and it went out into the market.
We needed to prove
that there is a market.
For $2 million,
you better be selling me
on where this is
in 10 or 15 years
that's gonna revolutionize
the world
instead of a backup battery
that goes on your phone.
All right.
What I plan on doing
to be able to change the world
is this image right here.
The reason why we have
the extensive patent portfolio,
why we have a device and We've
commercialized something
as a proof of concept
was because this technology
applies to mass-Wave-Energy
power generation.
So what you're saying --
You're gonna put them
in the ocean,
and you're gonna Harness
the power of waves.
That is affirmative.
From walking to wave --
Capturing energy from waves.
Well, we've been able
to demonstrate
that we can take
normal human walking
and make usable power off of it.
The exact same technology
is able to do the same thing
in waves.
Is it comparable to wind?
Is it better than solar?
It's comparable to wind,
and the studies that we've done
show that the power we could
produce from a wave farm
would be price-comparable
to coal-Fired power.
It seems to me that there are
at least three companies
that are
in the turbine business
that might be interested
in this technology.
Why isn't all the energy
of this company
to simply take these patents
and go and license it
and prove this concept,
which is ultimately
the best use of this technology?
This is crap
compared to that.
Why are wasting
with a little shake weight
when you can go
and start in the water
and start working
on smaller concepts there?
It's a company.
We've got a product.
So that's what it's about
right now --
You're trying to create revenue
because you need the Revenue.
Correct.
Okay. That's fair.
The reality is you said you've
sold 1,300 of these at $199,
so you've made $130,000
off of these things.
You know, that's very,
very commendable.
If you would have
walked in here
and said, "Look at
this operating business.
"I just made $130,000
in a few years.
"This product's selling.
"Help me get started,
and with your connections,
let me tease you with this,"
I might have bitten.
Okay.
But when you try to sell us
on your plan
and ask for $2 million,
that's a different beast
altogether,
so I have to
tell you I'm out.
I think
you're brilliant.
I hope that
you find a way
in which to make
this dream come True.
But I don't know
that I'm the right person
to help you get to such a big,
global level.
So for that reason,
I'm out,
but I wish you
good luck.
Thank you very much.
Aaron, you know,
the only thing
that I worry more about
than the debt in America
is our consumption
of energy.
Something's got to change.
There's got to be
new technologies.
There's got to be new ways
to create it.
This could be part
of the answer --
I don't really know --
but I'm not making
the connection
between this and that.
I'm just not seeing it.
I'm out.
Okay.
Keep in mind, the strategy here
is crawl, walk, run.
This is crawling.
We have other business
development opportunities
that are in our pipeline
that are actually starting
to create revenue
at this point, too,
like the military application --
Being able to reduce
the battery weight
of soldiers in combat by 25%
by harvesting the power
that already exists
on the battlefield.
John: You're a smart guy.
I can't add value.
I'm just not excited
about it.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Well, I think at this point,
four sharks are out
and only Kevin is left.
Okay, Aaron, you know,
as far as I'm concerned,
you've proven
the concept.
Whether or not this is
a successful retail product
is irrelevant
when that's the prize.
And I think it's
very interesting technology.
If it's true,
if you have some proof
that this is equivalent to
the efficiency of burning coal,
this is obviously
a better solution.
So what I would have
liked to have done
is said,
"I'll get on board.
I'll buy a piece
of this company,
and I'll take it to g.E."
But I can't play,
'cause it costs me $2 million
so that I can work for you.
How twisted is that?
Sounds like America
to me.
No.
It sounds like
you made a mistake to me.
I'm not gonna pay you $2 million
and then do the heavy lifting.
That's insane.
That's un-American.
I'm out.
Okay.
All the best.
Thank you all very much
for your time.
I really do appreciate it.
I think
he's got something.
I hope he makes it.
Yeah, I do too.
I feel strongly
that we're on the right path,
we're doing the right stuff
and we're gonna be growing
our clean technology
into a multibillion-dollar
company.
Narrator: Next into the tank
is Nathan Holdsaffle,
with a new twist
to a common men's accessory.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Nate Holdsaffle.
And I'm founder
of the Mission Belt Company,
and we're seeking $50,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in our company.
Everyone owns a belt --
Most people own a few --
and in a thousand years,
this everyday accessory
Has hardly ever changed.
And some people might ask,
"Why reinvent the wheel?"
at the mission belt company,
we've asked, "Why not?"
so we set on a mission to
improve this everyday accessory.
For starters...
careful.
...we removed all the holes.
We've also employed
our unique ratchet system
to allow it to go together.
You can hear the clicks
as it goes together, feeds...
[ clicking ]
...slowly,
and use the release lever
on the bottom to take it apart.
It's like a giant zip tie
for your pants.
Now, sharks,
I'm a big, husky guy,
and keeping my pants on
is a full-time job, okay?
[ laughter ]
I wear out so many belts.
I wear all kinds of belts.
It is for Kevin, also.
[ laughter ]
Okay, O'Leary, we got something
in common. That's good.
Keeping up my pants
is a full-time job
because I wear them out so quick
and the holes
are what cause the problem.
Regardless of my caloric intake,
the mission belt's gonna give me
the perfect fit every time,
and it's gonna last a long time.
Sharks, with your help,
I believe I could put
one of these belts
around the waist
of everyone in America.
Let's make a deal.
Is that all it does
is ratchet on?
Yep.
Can we see them?
Sure.
Harrington:
Thank you.
Oh, it's well made.
It's very well made.
Do you manufacture
these, Nate?
I sure do.
Yourself, or do you --
No, I actually employ
a factory to do it.
This is as high a quality belt
as I could make
and still make it
comfortable price.
But nobody can make a belt
just like the mission belt.
Our unique style, our design,
and frankly, the quality
and the effort we put together
to make these belts
is unique and special.
What's the distribution
plan?
How are you gonna get this
in every store
where Men's and Women's clothes
are sold?
That's exactly my biggest Hurdle
that I'm gonna have.
I need a rolodex.
I'm a good salesman,
but I can't get in front
of the right people.
Tell us about the stores
you're selling in right now.
They're small, local retailers.
I'm in a couple
of country clubs,
a couple
of men's clothier places,
and really,
it's the number-one-selling belt
in each of these locations.
What are they
reordering?
Is it because they're selling
three a week or 20 or 30
or you're really
doing well?
The orders are going up.
I have one location
that sells 250 a month.
250 belts a month?
Greiner: A month?
In one location out of those 22.
What does it sell for?
35 bucks.
How much have you made
last year?
We've only been in business
for three months.
How much have you sold?
$39,000 worth of product.
In three months?
Yep.
Pretty darn good
for belts.
John:
That is really Good.
Wow.
What's it cost to make them,
and what are you wholesaling
them for?
Right now, even in the small
quantities I'm building them,
I can build them for anywhere
from about $5.50 to $6,
shipped here in the U.S.
With a tag.
And what's your wholesale?
$15.
$15?
Mm-hmm.
Margins are okay.
Margins are good.
The biggest challenge
is the demonstration of that.
If it's just hanging there,
we have no idea what it was.
We were all looking at it,
and you don't
hear the ratcheting.
You don't understand it.
How do I walk into a store,
see that display,
see mission belt --
How do I know it does that?
What I've gone ahead and done
in these 22 locations
is I've taken
some Real personal effort
and I've gone to each one
of them,
and I pay attention
to the salespeople.
"Hi. How are you?
My name's nate."
"And Here's a belt."
"Here's a belt.
You want to try one on?"
I have every salesperson
who sells them wear them.
The reality of it is, once you
wear one of these belts,
it's really hard to consider
anything else for the pants,
because it adjusts
to every quarter-Inch.
A lot of belts, it's like
it fits and then it doesn't.
Especially for big guys.
I weigh 250, man.
You don't want to buy
a 42-Inch.
I lost 10 pounds
last week,
and I might gain 10 pounds
tomorrow
because I'm in l.A.
And I love food.
[ laughter ]
the reality of it is
that my belt will fit.
And it always broadcasts
to the world
how much weight you've gained
or lost or whatever.
This belt doesn't show any wear.
When I decided I wanted
to try to sell these,
I thought,
"I'm gonna do a test market."
And I went out
to a local swap meet.
I took 100 belts with me.
Two hours later,
the belts were gone,
and I knew
at that point right there
that I had something unique
and special.
I sold some Belts door-To-Door
here in west hollywood.
I want to say
it was saturday night.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You came to L.A.
And one of
the first things you did
when you get
to Los Angeles --
I check in,
got nothing else to do,
evening to myself.
I went and sold 20 belts
door-to-door.
I love you.
I love you!
Are their any other ones
like this?
There are.
There are?
Holdsaffle: Yeah, there's
products that are like it.
It's called a t-Belt.
But, Lori,
they don't ratchet like this.
No, they don't ratchet,
which is why I'm saying --
the t-Belt's where
they just get snug, right?
John:
Yeah, the army ones.
But they never work properly
over time.
They sure don't,
and lot of times, too,
a nylon belt's really cool,
but I wouldn't wear a nylon belt
with anything you're wearing.
I think it's very tough
to actually get distribution
of just five
or six belts.
But with the right person
as a partner,
with the right rolodex --
I'm not asking anyone
to sell this belt for me.
We don't need to hire
a sales force.
I am a sales force.
We can go out and do this.
I love him.
What I need is to get
the appointments.
With the right names
and the right references,
I can get in front
of these places.
Right now I bat 1.000.
Everybody who I pitch the belt
to who can make a decision buys.
I think you're great.
You're a hero.
It's very innovative.
I like it a lot.
And I think that men could use
a product like this.
The only problem
is I see this product
as something that really
needs to be demonstrated,
and I think it would be
difficult to show it in,
let's say, jcpenney
in 1,000-Plus stores.
You're not gonna get
the sales force
to be able to talk about it
enough,
because there's hundreds
of products per floor.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
No problem. Thank you very much
for your opinion.
I appreciate it.
I like the product.
I think this is
a big distribution play.
I think it will sell
wherever it goes.
Getting it into the stores is
gonna be a significant challenge
that I'm not up for,
but I will buy one from you.
I like the product a lot.
I'm gonna use it.
But I'm out.
Is there a problem at all
if someone's really skinny
where there's just
too much belt hanging over?
No.
I know you don't have
that problem.
I don't have that problem,
but there are some.
It's actually a cool feature.
My son Lorenzo
is 4 1/2 years old.
He's a little guy.
He's skinny.
And he wanted a mission belt.
You take the belts off.
The Buckles
are totally interchangeable.
But how do you
make it smaller?
Cut it down.
I guess it doesn't matter.
The ends don't matter, right?
Sure. You can make it
as small as you want.
But if you're in a men's store,
if you're thin,
you're not gonna
want to cut a belt.
We have different sizes,
though.
We have small, medium, large,
and extra large right now.
You know, for me,
it's a pure licensing play.
And I'm open to licensing.
I'm not a person
who has an agenda.
I want to get things done.
I want to make things work.
The thing about it
is that in the end of the day,
it's not just $50,000.
I do need that rolodex,
and I need financial depth.
Well, I think everybody here
can give you the rolodex.
Everybody here can give you
the financial depth,
but I think if you want to sell
belts to other stores,
I'm probably
not your partner.
I'm out.
How much did you say
you invested?
Right now,
we're about $90,000.
You don't have any debt,
no big credit cards backed up?
No credit cards.
I sold my car to do belts.
I'm eating peanut Butter
and jelly sandwiches.
It's not as bad as ketchup.
Ketchup and Mustard is good.
You ought to try it sometime.
I'm not that desperate yet,
but coming up on it soon.
Right now it's pb&js.
But just doing my part
to try and Make things work.
I'm a person who's patient,
reasonable,
and I want to
make something happen.
So three sharks are out.
Mark and Daymond,
what are you going to do?
Narrator:
Three sharks are out.
Daymond and Mark are Nathan's
last chance to make a deal.
You're impressive.
Very impressive guy.
So let me
enlighten you.
Accessories are
the hottest thing selling now,
But just one design of a belt
is not a business.
Holdsaffle: Right.
Right?
That's for sure.
That's the biggest
challenge,
but I'm really impressed
by you.
Getting off the plane and
walking around West Hollywood
and selling belts
door-to-door --
Cuban:
And let me just say,
I relate to that, because I sold
garbage bags door-to-door.
I sold candy
door-to-door.
I sold greeting cards
Yeah.
I sold magazines
door-to-door.
You name it, I sold it.
Takes guts.
No, it just takes
confidence.
So, what are you gonna do?
Are you doing something?
I'm patient.
Oh, you want to wait
for me?
Exactly.
Okay. No problem.
John:
Doing this offer,
I would really want it to be
for a license reason,
but the biggest challenge
with that is
you're the best salesman.
So we would have to
do something
where we license it
to a company,
but you also do sales
and you're the head of sales
and you get a commission
for that as well.
I will make you
an offer...
...for $50,000
and 40% of the company.
We're gonna take it, obviously,
to a license guy,
a partner of mine,
and they're gonna do
all the manufacturing,
product development,
and you'll also
head up the sales team.
That's my offer.
Take his offer.
I'm out.
Would you settle for 30%?
I will absolutely settle
for 37.5%.
Daymond, I'd be crazy
to not want a partner like you.
I accept 100%.
My man.
[ cracks belt ]
Harrington: Wow.
That's a deal.
That is a deal.
What a dream come true
for me.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It's a pleasure
to meet you.
[ laughs ]
Congratulations.
I'm happier about being
in business with him.
You should be.
Yeah, he's gonna call me
every morning
and say, "Hey, why don't you
get up and do something?"
I was able to get a deal
with Daymond, of all people --
Just so lucky.
I couldn't have dreamt it
any better.
It's just absolutely wonderful.